This is Jocko podcast number one 55 with me,
Jocko Willink
on the island.
The dead were piling up.
Yeah.
In the mission report,
the head of the convoy wrote at 2:00 PM on May 20th I went to the island of
[inaudible] know with command dirt taps scoff.
There was a terrible scramble.
People crowding and fighting around the bags of flour,
dead bodies everywhere.
A hundred or more and Matsu people crawling about and crying give us bread boss.
It's been two days since we've been given anything to eat.
They're trying to make us die of hunger and the cold.
They told us that people had begun eating the dead bodies,
that they were cooking human flesh.
The scene on the island was dreadful.
Appalling.
On May 21st alone,
the three health officer's counted 70 additional dead bodies in five cases.
They emphasized the liver,
the heart,
the lungs and fleshy part of bodies.
Okay.
Had been caught off.
Yeah.
On one of the bodies,
the head had been torn off along the,
along with the male genital organs and part of the skin.
These mutilations constitutes strong evidence of cannibalistic acts.
In addition,
they suggest the existence of serious psychopathology.
He's on the same day.
May 21st the deportees themselves brought us three individuals who had been
caught with blood on their hands and holding human livers.
Our examination of these three individuals did not reveal any extreme and
maceration
and there an elderly,
local peasant woman who reported the things we saw.
People were dying everywhere.
They were killing each other.
There was a guard name Kostia the Nico off a young fellow.
He was courting a pretty girl who had been sent there.
He protected her.
Yeah.
One day he had to be away for a while.
Yeah,
and he told one of his comrades.
Take care of her.
Yeah,
but with all the people,
the comrade couldn't do much.
People caught the girl,
tied her to a tree,
cut off her breasts,
her muscles,
everything they could eat.
They were hungry.
They had to eat.
When costs do you came back.
She was still alive.
He tried to save her,
but she had lost too much blood.
She died.
That was the kind of thing that happened
when you went along the island.
You saw flesh wrapped in rags.
Okay.
Human flesh that had been cut
and hung in the trees.
Okay.
And that right there is from a book called Cannibal Island by Nicholas worth,
who's written books about communism.
I think his most famous as the black book of communism and Cannibal Island
specifically breaks down one of the small individual nightmares of the Soviet
gulags.
But the nightmare was not small and it certainly was not specific.
It was widespread and it was broad
and it was almost incomprehensible
and very little about it would be known or not.
For one man,
Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn,
who not only survived the gulags but lived on to write incredibly detailed and
very well researched books about the gulags.
Some of them were fictionalized
like a day in the life of Ivan Denisovich and for the,
for the good of the cause,
but most comprehensively and his three volume tome,
the Gulag archipelago.
And this series is,
is a massive series and it's been cut down to an abridged version that was
actually approved by the author himself.
And the abridged version has just been rereleased in Europe with a forward by a
man that I think repopulate,
buys that book,
a man that is here today to discuss that book.
And among other things,
I'm sure a man that I needed to give an introduction to the first time he was on
this podcast,
but now who needs no introduction whatsoever,
a man by the name of Dr. Jordan B.
Peterson.
Jordan,
thank you for coming back on.
How's it rough beginning Jocko.
Jesus.
Uh,
yeah,
I remember when I started listening to you,
you would say something along the lines of that,
you know,
we are quite capable of creating hell for ourselves as human beings and that
clearly that situation.
I don't know.
I mean that's,
that's,
that's hell yeah.
And close enough.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's,
it's created by us.
It's created by us,
which I think is,
um,
obviously horrific and the Gulag archipelago,
you know,
you,
you talked about that book a lot and,
and one of the things that in that book hits you hard obviously for me,
uh,
there's a book called about face by Colonel David Hackworth.
I'm from a different world I guess.
Then you,
in many ways,
the book that hit me hardest in my life was,
was that book about face and it's,
it's one of those things that when I read it,
I started putting it together.
It's like things started to fit and
I remember that and I was wondering,
I guess from my perspective,
at what point did you read the Gulag archipelago and at what point did you start
to say,
okay,
there's something really,
really important here for me to try and understand?
Well,
I read it back in the 1980s,
early,
I would say I'd read some Solzhenitsyn before that.
I read the light of day,
day of a day in the life of Ivan Denisovich when I was about 13 or 14.
And then I read the Gulag archipelago in my early twenties,
uh,
when I was reading a lot of psychological material too when I started reading
young and Freud and the great clinicians and uh,
or he's reading a fair bit about what had happened in Nazi Germany at the same
time.
And also Viktor Frankl's man's search for meaning.
And Solzhenitsyn's book is in some ways like an elaborated extension of Frankel
Frankel of course described what happened to him in the Nazi concentration
camps.
And it's a relatively short book and it's a great book.
But soldier Nixon's book is,
it's,
it's much broader and,
and I would say deeper.
And the thing that affected me most particularly was the psychological take on
the,
on the totalitarian states.
You know,
I had been studying political science up to that point and the political science
scientists and the economists who I would say we're under the sway of Marxists
thinking,
although not nearly to the degree that they are now,
we're convinced that the reason that people engaged in conflict was basically a
consequence of argumentation over resources,
you know,
is basically an economic argument.
And I never bought that.
It never made sense to me.
I mean,
obviously there are circumstances where that's true,
but it didn't seem to be fundamentally the case.
Like tribal warfare isn't precisely about resources.
It's maybe it's about territory or maybe it's about identity.
But it never seemed to me to be simply about resources.
Um,
partly because,
well a resource is something that people value,
but it isn't obvious why people value what they value.
And so it doesn't solve the fundamental problem.
Anyways.
When I was reading Frankel and Solzhenitsyn,
I started to more deeply understand the relationship between the individual and
the atrocity.
And that's what I found most interesting was that Frankel's claim and
Solzhenitsyn's claim as well,
that it was the moral corruption of the citizenry that allowed the totalitarian
catastrophes to occur.
And that that in some sense was the responsibility of every individual in the
system who looked the other way or who participated actively.
I mean,
even in the gulag camps themselves,
they were almost all run by the prisoners.
There wasn't enough administrative manpower to run the prison system without the
cooperation,
so to speak,
of the prisoners.
So it is,
it is a surreal sort of hell where you imprison yourself and Solzhenitsyn's
fundamental claim.
And this was true for Franklin as well,
and also for Vaclav Havel who eventually became president of Czechoslovakia,
or at least of the Czech Republic,
I don't remember which,
you know,
they believe that it was the individual proclivity to accept lies that fostered
the ability of tyrants to destroy the state.
And then,
well,
and that also led to complicitness with regards to all the absolute atrocities
that were occurring in both the Nazi state,
in the and in the Soviet state.
And I think that's true when I read,
like I read soldier knits and spokes in a lot of the books I read about Nazi
Germany to not as a victim and not as a hero,
but as a perpetrator,
you know,
which I think it's really important.
It's something that's really important to do when you read history is that it's
easy to cast yourself as a victim.
It's easy to cast yourself as the person who would have been heroic in the
circumstance,
but it's also unbelievably useful to understand that there's a good chance.
Had you been in those situations that you wouldn't have been on the side of the
good guys and no,
and that's a terrible,
it's really a terrible realization,
but it's,
it's necessary realization.
Again,
just going back to this idea of what you get of reading,
because people
ask me now because I read books all the time on my podcast and what you just
said,
it struck me as something that's,
people have told me,
I read that book before,
but I didn't really get out of it.
What you got out of it and when I heard you read it [inaudible] I was saying,
wow,
how did I need to go reread this book?
And I think one of the key things is you looked at these books as you were not
the victim,
but the perpetrator.
One thing that when I read books,
I know I read a lot of books,
mostly about war for me,
I always think about the,
the peep.
I don't know what we see myself as the person that goes and heroically storms
the beaches and survives every,
you know,
in a war book,
there's these people that get mentioned for it,
for up for a half a paragraph,
for,
for two sentences.
And that sometimes they don't even have a name because you know,
you're the battalion commander is storming the beach at Normandy.
You don't,
you're not going to name every single person,
but for some reason,
and maybe it's just my experiences of being in combat,
when I read about that two sentences of that guy,
that that gets shot,
that gets killed,
that gets blown up.
I completely understand and relate to that person.
Like I,
I don't just see it as me being the guy that is always winning and always doing
okay and always surviving.
I feel and relate to those guys that didn't.
And part of that is just because of my friends that I lost in combat.
Like those guys,
they're their people.
And I think that key thing of,
of reading it and going,
man,
every single person,
like when you read about these group,
you're talking about millions of people that were tortured,
died,
murdered.
Every one of those people,
the keyword is people.
Every one of those people is a person.
And to your point,
every single one of those executioners,
every single one of those murderers is also a personal,
there's a great book called ordinary men.
Oh yeah,
we,
we reviewed that on this podcast.
Right,
right.
And so,
you know,
it's,
it's one of the greatest books written about what happened in the Second World
War,
I think on the end of,
on the atrocity and [inaudible] because the author does such a lovely job of,
while it's a strange way of putting it in this context,
but you know,
it's about this police battalion that was moved into Poland after the Germans
went through and,
and occupied the country and they were there to establish order like police do,
but also to participate in the mopping up,
let's say.
Uh,
that was part and parcel of the war.
And you know,
these were ordinary policemen,
um,
middleclass guys,
most of whom had been educated and socialized before the Nazi propaganda machine
really got rolling.
So they weren't like Hitler youth.
Um,
they were ordinary men and they were brought and they had a commander who had
made an explicit case that if they weren't able to tolerate the conditions in
Poland that they could go home.
So there was no top down order that you had to do this or else.
And then they were,
you know,
first of all they started rounding up while mostly Jewish people,
men between 18 and 65 and then,
you know,
they started to participate in the entire atrocious mess and they were,
they ended up many of them taking naked pregnant women out into fields and
shooting them in the back of the head.
And what the author does is outline how that happens to you,
you know,
one step at a time.
And so it's a really horrifying book and it's a brilliant book because there's
no attempt to make the perpetrators like some creatures that aren't human,
like just pure psychopaths.
And of course in an situation like Nazi Germany and and in the horrors of the
communist states,
there was no shortage of places for psychopaths to prevail.
But that's not really the issue.
The issue is,
well,
how does an ordinary person come to participate in a global horror,
let's say?
And what does that mean about being an ordinary person?
And then the next question is,
well,
what does it mean about how you should conduct your life?
And one of the things that,
I mean,
I think what happened to me when I read all this material in the 80s was that I
became convinced that there wasn't anything more important to do in the
aftermath of what had happened in the 20th century.
Then to try to build people who were responsible enough as truth telling
courageous,
responsible citizens so that the probability would increase,
that if they were in a position to make a terrible choice,
that they would make the right one.
And I would say this lecture tour that I'm doing,
which is now extended over more than a hundred cities,
is an extension of the same thing.
Well,
I think it's the same thing that you're trying to do with your book.
Like we were just looking at your Mickey and the dragons book,
right?
And you're trying to lay out,
um,
uh,
psychological pathway that guides people towards responsibility and courage and
truth and all of that.
And that is the bull bark against tyranny.
And it's actually the,
it's actually at the individual level.
And we kind of know that,
like,
we,
we know that in the west,
I think that's part of the core ethos of,
well,
certainly that of,
of the English common law system,
certainly of the American way of looking at the world is that each citizen is
the bulwark against tyranny.
And that's actually true.
It's,
and,
and that's a terrible thing to,
to think through because it means that you are responsible for the integrity or
lack thereof of your state.
And it's,
it's on you,
you know,
and,
and there's something great about that because it means that your existence
actually matters to you and to your family.
And,
and to the broader community in a really major way,
in a way that's much more significant than you might think.
And that the,
your proclivity to abdicate your moral responsibility echoes way farther than
you might consider,
especially under some circumstances,
you know,
in soldier knits.
And one of the things that's so amazing about the Gulag archipelago is his
stories not only of the absolute bloody catastrophe of the Soviet state and his
incredibly astute documentation of the role that the utopian,
political and philosophical assumptions of Marxism played in creating the
system,
right?
It wasn't an aberration,
it was a direct,
logical consequence of that collectivist viewpoint.
And to document all that,
but also to tell endless stories about people who were able,
at least to some degree,
to not become corrupted,
even under unbelievably horrific conditions,
you know?
And,
and that's something you also get out of Viktor Frankl's book man's search for
meaning,
you know,
and um,
and so the Gulag archipelago is a story about horror in some sense,
but it's more a story of the triumph of the fundamental triumph of the human
spirit and perhaps no more,
uh,
perhaps most evident in the case of soldier.
And it's an himself because he memorized this book in some sense while he was in
the camps and then wrote it under extreme duress afterwards.
And it's an immense undertaking and it's unbelievably emotionally intense.
The entire book.
It's like one,
you know,
1700 page scream of outrage.
You just can hardly believe that someone can write at that white hot intensity
for such a long period of time.
And you know,
his book had an unbelievable global impact.
I think it's sold 30 million copies and it definitely,
for at least a reasonable period of time made it completely untenable for,
um,
utopian resentful,
Utopian intellectuals to ethically justified their radical leftist collectivism.
It,
it just blew the slats out from underneath any ethical credibility that
communism,
that,
that remained of the communist doctrine by the 1970s and that that's a hell of a
thing for someone to manage on their own.
It's a pretty big task.
Uh,
so while you were going through that,
I was thinking myself sauce,
I was talking to,
I still talk to military folks and I was talking to some military leaders,
young leaders,
so like platoon level and company level leaders.
So these are guys that are in charge of,
you know,
40 guys or maybe 150 guys
and,
and you know,
you can have some real ethical problems.
And,
and one of the things that I said to this group was I said,
hey,
in your s in your platoon,
you've got a murderer in your platoon,
you've got someone in your platoon that has a sadist.
And the,
they were kind of looking at me,
um,
suspect,
you know,
a little bit like,
oh,
come on now,
come on.
What are you talking about?
How big is the platoon?
A platoon is 40 guys.
Oh yeah.
And I was,
I was actually going to ask you how accurate I was and then I was going to
actually say that no matter what you say,
how accurate is even if it was,
even if it was one out of every thousand,
you have to act as a leader,
as if in your platoon you've got one of those guys are two of those guys.
That's a way you need to act.
Look,
and there's another book called the Rape of Nan King.
We've covered that.
So one of the things that was really horrifying about that book is,
so imagine that there's maybe let's say that there's one in a hundred just for
the sake of argument that's really got cruel and psychopathic traits.
What do you think professionally,
what do you think that number is?
Oh,
I think 1% isn't unreasonable and it could be higher than that.
I mean there's gradations,
right?
Right.
Yeah.
There's probably in a group of 40 people,
there's going to be one guy in there who's proclivity in that direction is
sufficiently strong so that you better keep an eye on him.
That's for sure.
And this is a group of people that joined the military,
right?
So they're already,
you know,
you've already gotten,
you've already got a group that's okay with,
with theoretically having to kill other people.
So this is,
you know,
so if it's 100 islands,
that's likely an underestimate.
So I think your estimate is perfectly reasonable and it might be conservative.
What happened in Nan king was that the most sadistic people became the targets
of imitation and emulation.
And that's when things really get out of hand.
Right?
So,
and that's the same thing for me,
Lai massacre.
And,
and that was so,
so when I was talking to this group and I'm getting it,
I said to him,
I said,
you're looking at me like right now.
Like,
I'm like,
I don't know what I'm talking about.
Or like I'm crazy.
Who knows about the meal?
I'm masker and,
and you know,
all of a sudden it got quiet because if you know anything about the mee Lai
massacre,
it was a normal group of guys.
It was a normal group of guys.
It was a normal company of American soldiers.
And you know what,
they'd been through some stress they'd been through,
you know,
they'd,
they'd had their friends killed and it was in Vietnam.
There was no one really to react against or to,
to,
to take your aggression out on because the enemy,
you couldn't see them.
They would hide.
And it was,
but then they turned and they snapped.
And the same thing you had the leader,
um,
a guy named lieutenant Calley who was a platoon leader who eat,
Yo,
I'd love for you to do a psychological profile maybe who he used one of these
guys that was kind of like,
was it totally insecure about everything?
And so he got those shoulder boards on,
which is the way,
which is the way Soltra missing.
He describes his,
his experience being a platoon leader.
Yeah.
And what it did to him.
And he goes through that.
This book is fantastic to hear.
When he talks about what he did,
he knew he was looking back saying,
oh,
I did this and I didn't listen to this little rampage of things that he,
how he acted as a commander.
I ate the food,
the good food right in front of my guys when they weren't getting from,
I was getting the good food and he did took advantage of all the little,
all the little comforts that you got being an officer and you know,
yeah.
Well he was trying in the whole book and especially in that section,
which I think is in volume two,
which I think is the greatest of the three volumes,
especially the last half of it,
which is just absolutely
genius level writing.
Unbelievably compelling and brilliant.
And yeah,
I mean he,
he said that when he was in the camps that one of the things that he did,
especially once he started to identify people that he truly admired,
was to go over his life with a fine tooth comb and try to try to remember
everything that he did wrong by his own estimation and then try to set it right
in some manner.
And so there was a,
that's a repentance and then a redemption,
right?
There's,
there's a real,
there's a real fundamental,
like a medieval Christian undertone to all of that.
But it was one of the things that's quite interesting is that when you talk
about issues that are this serious,
you're almost inevitably in a situation where you're going to find yourself
compelled to use some kind of quasi religious language because you end up
discussing good and evil and and issues of redemption and issues of repentance
and issues of conscience and sin and all of that.
There isn't language that's deep enough to get out it otherwise.
And what Solzhenitsyn did was scour his conscience and try to put himself
together partly because he was shamed.
He was ashamed of himself in the face of these extraordinarily extraordinary
people who seem to be able to keep their moral compass under circumstances where
no one should ever assume that they would keep their moral compass.
Because certainly,
like I said,
when I was reading this,
the Gulag and other books like that,
I never assumed that if I was in those situations that I would have been one of
the people who kept their head.
And we're able to withstand the temptation to become a trustee,
for example,
and to take things the easy way and to Lord it over the other prisoners and to
and to adopt that position of authority.
You know,
it's like,
it's like a head slave among slaves,
but you know,
you could say well better to be the head slave than to be the bottom slave.
And while that's true in some sense with regards to creature comfort,
but as Solzhenitsyn point out points out,
it might be a little bit hard on your soul.
And that actually turns out to be something of of crucial,
not only crucial,
important psychologically,
but crucial importance sociologically and politically.
Because if you sacrifice that,
then you warp the structure around you,
which is exactly what happened in the establishment of these camps.
You know,
in the Soviet Union was just one big lie.
What was their old joke?
They pretend to pay us and we pretend to work.
It's like
the whole,
the whole book and the whole Soviet Union.
When you,
when you read about it now it seems like it's,
it,
it seems like a bad joke.
It seems like a bad movie.
You could,
just,
the way,
the way that Stalin would do something and,
and the way that that order would come down,
it seems like one of those cheesy,
um,
you know,
comedic movies about these decisions that they're making and it's surreal.
It's completely,
it's completely insane.
You know,
at one point he's talking about the,
there was a,
a new penalty for what they call it,
sh clipping corn or,
or they're basically a 12 year old kid would be starving and you'd go into a
field and eat and,
and clip a cure,
a,
a core,
an ear of corn.
And that happened in the Ukraine during the DQ localization,
right.
It was against the law to go out after the fields were,
were harvested.
It was against the law to go out and pick grain off the ground to feed your
family.
Right.
And the prison sentence was like a tenor,
which is their little work for 10 years.
So you're going to get,
you steal a piece of corn or you've pick up corn off the ground and you're
getting 10 years.
Yep.
You can't comprehend that.
That is very hard to come here.
She worked and they were the,
the,
you know,
he does in the earlier parts of the book when he starts going through the trials
that they were doing on people.
Yeah.
It's completely crazy.
It's king.
It's cash.
Well that's why I hate to see the kangaroo courts emerging all over,
all over the west,
you know,
and,
and with the university sort of at the forefront of that.
So we're,
we're building these alternative court systems constantly that don't follow
standard legal procedure and it's really,
we're messing with things that,
that we shouldn't be messing with.
And Yeah,
the whole,
I mean there,
there are accounts,
I believe it's in the Gulag of,
of,
of applause after Astellas,
the speech,
right,
where people would stand up and applaud and they,
and they'd applaud until,
until literally the old people were falling over.
Because if you were the first person to stop applauding,
then you were,
well,
it was off to the camps with you.
Absolutely.
Outlines.
That sounds so crazy to say.
And he,
he outlines a specific thing that happened.
Is that right there?
These no one will stop applauding.
Yeah.
Because they're afraid they're gonna get ratted out by there.
Bye Bye everyone.
Yeah,
well Ben and by the people who are in fact watching,
and I mean,
you know,
by,
by the end,
by the,
by the collapse of East Germany,
one third of the people were in Fort Informers for the state.
And so if you had a family of six people,
two of your family members were direct government informers you know,
and it's,
it's so it's,
it's creepy in some sense.
It's a very weak word to use in this situation.
But I'll go,
when I was at New York University talking to Jonathan Heit about,
I dunno,
it was about a few months ago,
um,
he just wrote that book called the coddling of the American mind,
you know,
and,
uh,
he took me into one of the men's washrooms there and there was a poster on the
wall asking students to turn each other in four instances of bias or offensive
speech.
And they have a whole bureaucracy that's designed to do nothing else but
adjudicate these instances of biased speech.
And these posters are up on the walls as if this is something to be proud of.
You know,
and the same thing is happening now in Scotland with the Scottish police are
doing exactly the same thing.
They're asking citizens to turn each other in for,
for hate crimes.
You know?
And the problem with that is the fundamental problem with that and the,
the unsolvable problem is well who defines hate and,
and where's,
where's the line drawn?
It's like,
well anything that upsets me that you say is hate that.
And then it's worse than that.
It's like what happens is the people who define hate ended up being those who
are looking to take offense so that they can find someone they can define as a
victimizer so that they can persecute them morally and justify that inner
sadism.
And those are the people who end up defining the laws and then they mask this
with the morality saying,
well,
we're doing this to make our society a safe place.
It's absolutely,
it's,
it's absolutely dreadful.
And to see that happening in the UK was just,
it's just awful because I mean,
you know,
the UK is center a center,
a center point of,
of the idea of free speech.
I mean,
a lot of America,
obviously a lot of American ideals.
America is a great center of free speech,
but I mean,
it's a variation on the English system.
So to see that happening in the UK is just,
it's awful.
And to see the police doing this and being,
you know,
I'm encouraged by the politicians and,
and,
and to see this put forward as some sort of moral action,
it's just,
well,
it's,
it's an echo of this kind of catastrophe that,
that we're discussing.
So I think about that sometimes.
And I also have a tendency to look at things in La,
not be too worried about him.
Like,
Hey,
c'mon,
yeah,
but what's really going to happen?
Right.
And that's,
yeah,
that's actually part of my personality.
And part of that comes from my old job where,
hey,
I can't worry about these little things.
Oh,
there's some little problem going on over there.
That's,
that's not gonna be,
that's not gonna affect us.
It's not going to,
and you got to pay attention a little bit,
make sure it doesn't get out of hand.
But that thing about speech and you just mentioned the,
uh,
the Kulak.
Is that how is that our school lacks?
Yeah.
Yup.
They were the Ukrainian,
they were the Ukrainian farmers who were good at farming.
When I read this part,
um,
it got me worried about my own personal,
lackadaisical attitude towards things that I think all that's not big of a deal.
Let me,
let me read this little section about the,
about the escalation of the word Kulak Yep.
And,
and where it started and where that,
yeah.
That's good.
So here we go.
Um,
in Russian,
a Kulak is a miserly,
dishonest,
rural trader who grows rich,
not by his own labor,
but through someone else's.
Yeah.
In every locality,
even before the revolution.
Such cool acts could be numbered on one's fingers and the revolution totally
destroyed their basis of activity.
Subsequently after 1917 by a transfer of meaning,
the name Kulak began to be applied to all those who in any way hired workers.
Even if it was only,
even if it was only when they were temporarily short of working hands in their
own families.
Yeah,
but,
and that doesn't stop there.
The inflation of this scathing,
the term of this scathing term coop Kulak proceeded relentlessly and by 1930 all
strong peasants in general,
we're being so called all peasants strong in management,
strong in work,
or even strong merely in convictions.
The term Kulak was used to smash the strength of the peasantry and I gotta I
gotta go a little bit further because hell of a good thing for the workers party
to do a crazy.
Yep.
They went further though.
Beyond this in every village there were people who in one way or another had
personally gotten in the way of the local activists.
This was the perfect time to settle accounts with them of jealousy,
envy,
an insult.
These are the people you were just talking about.
A new word was needed for these new victims as a class.
And it was born by this time,
it had no social or an economic content whatsoever,
but it had a marvelous sound pop Kulak nick.
And that meant a person eating the cool acts.
In other words,
I consider you an accomplice of the enemy.
Hmm.
Yup.
And that's all it.
Yeah.
Well,
one of the things I tried to outline in my forward to the abridged version was I
was thinking about this idea of oddly enough about intersectionality,
which is,
uh,
like social justice idea.
You know,
that the social justice ideas that were best defined by our collective identity
and that the proper narrative in relationship to our collective identity is one
of victim victimizer,
which is a replay of the old Marxist doctrine of bourgeoisie and proletariat.
It's just in its new guys.
Um,
I mean in that new guys developed,
at least in part in response to the Gulag archipelago because the old
proletariat bourgeoisie distinction became morally untenable.
So it just went underground and underwent this transformation.
The intersectional theorists point out that your status as a victimizer or a
victim is actually the intersection of your multiple identities.
And so,
and that's actually the Achilles heel of the collectivist notion and we can get
into why that is,
but there's a horror that goes along with that,
that people that's not obvious that I think contributed to exactly why the
Russian revolution went so horribly wrong.
And that is that.
So imagine that I could characterize you along five or six different dimensions
of group identity.
It's pretty easy.
And while you're male,
you're male of a certain age,
you're male of a certain age and economic class.
You're,
you have a certain sexual orientation,
you have a certain ethnicity,
um,
you have a certain race that's six groups right there.
And we could continue,
you know,
your parents had a certain socioeconomic class and so did your grandparents and,
and then your ethnic group had a certain privilege or lack thereof and you're
attractive or you're not attractive and you're intelligent or not intelligent.
And there's temple temperamental variability.
Like there's all sorts of ways of characterizing you according to your group.
Okay.
Now we might say that if we were compassionate people that we would take one of
those group identities are more.
And look at where your dispossessed and victimized.
Okay.
And we're gonna find some dimension along which you're less privileged than some
people.
Like maybe you come from a working class background despite the fact that you're
like a straight male.
And so you can be a victim on that dimension.
And so,
and that's kind of,
that's at least in part an element of intersectional theory,
right?
And that may be your,
your,
your oppression is the product of,
of your multiple victim,
like identities.
But that can easily be reversed because it's absolutely the case that I can take
any person and I can do add multidimensional analysis of their group identities
and I can find at least one dimension along which there the perpetrator,
not the victim,
they're the victimizer,
not the victim.
And as soon as I can identify a dimension along which there a victimizer,
then that justifies their persecution.
And so one of the things that you saw happening in the Russian revolution,
and it's very much akin to what you just described,
was that the,
the,
the borders of who who was validly accused of being a victimizer essentially
expanded to include every once.
And,
and that's actually right.
It's in a,
in a perverse sense,
it's right.
Because if you position yourself properly in the historical flow,
then you should see yourself as a perpetrator and a victim equally.
Well,
it's not the right way to see yourself at all.
But if you're going to play that game,
you're going to be on both sides of it.
And then that issue is,
and this is related to your idea about,
you know,
in your platoon,
you've got one person who's sadistic.
It's like,
okay,
well let's even assume that at the beginning of the Russian revolution,
that the vast majority of the people who were motivated by communism were
actually compassionate with regards to the dispossessed peasantry.
Now,
I don't believe that,
but we could say that that was even a significant minority.
Well,
the question is,
did you just say on it?
What was your,
what was your,
uh,
hypothetical percentage?
Well,
let's say,
well,
let's say it's 20%,
or let's even say it's 50% of people who are genuinely motivated by compassion
for the dispossessed,
but then there's another minority.
Maybe we could even say it was only 10% to begin with who weren't motivated by
that at all.
They were motivated by the jealousy and the spite and the,
and the,
and the resentment that Solzhenitsyn describes.
And they were the ones who are after those to be persecuted.
And the thing is they got the upper hand really rapidly.
And it might be because the carnivorous types,
the predatory types are much more dangerous and powerful than the compassionate
types.
Like they'll take them out instantly.
We're,
we're,
we're willing to step up and smash someone,
post the people that are saying,
oh,
we just want to help.
Yes,
exactly.
Well,
and,
and there,
there's someone I actually cited a guy named,
I think his name was Walter lots in the forward who,
who wrote,
uh,
wrote in a journal called red terror that if you were interrogating an enemy of
the state,
you didn't bother with niceties like their individual guilt.
That was a bourgeois z a conceit.
And then so that's really important thing to keep in mind.
What you wanted to do is to do a class based analysis and find out,
well,
are they a member of let's say the Qu lack or the affiliates of the Kulaks,
which is a lovely way of expanding your list of potential victims and then you,
you execute accordingly.
And that would mean,
well,
the person that you're interrogating,
right?
Or The class member that you're interrogating and then their children and
perhaps also their grandchildren and lots of himself was eventually executed by
the Stellan.
Somebody wrote to me after I wrote the foreword and told me that that was his
eventual fate.
And I thought,
well,
talk about standing on a chair and putting the new,
surround your own neck and kicking it out from underneath you.
It's like,
you know,
he basically,
he murdered himself fundamentally.
And,
and you know,
you could say in some sense,
that was the story of the Soviet Union to a,
to a tremendous degree.
There's,
there's one part going back to the ever expanding,
um,
people that need to be destroyed.
There was a point in,
in the book where he starts,
he's saying,
hey,
look,
there's insects.
Describe,
or maybe it was Lennon was describing these certain people as insects that
needed to be destroyed.
And then he just,
that that just starts off with,
hey,
people that are rabble rousers,
they're insects.
And,
and then it just expands and expands.
And then it's got priest and then it's got engineers and physicians.
Everyone [inaudible].
Yeah.
That's the,
that's the word that they use or that he uses in the book for a basically
saboteurs.
Yeah.
And that expands beyond comprehension.
Because at every single problem that there is,
is the fault of some person out there that sabotaging.
Yup.
And,
and they,
they do this show trial and he talks about it in the book for I th I think,
I think the phrase that he uses or that they use at the rush that the Soviets
used organizers of the famine,
meaning like,
Oh yeah,
you're starving.
And these people over here,
they're the reason you're,
these are the people that organize the famine.
They're the,
they're the records of production of food.
And you bet,
you bet.
Well,
it was either that,
you know,
you imagine that you,
you,
you adopt a worldview and that worldview enables you to,
at least in principle,
organize yourself with other people and to provide you with a certain amount of
psychological stability.
And then things go dreadfully wrong.
And then you have a choice which is to reevaluate your worldview,
which is of course what social needs and does in the gulag.
Archipelago in a very deep ways,
reorganized his entire worldview.
Um,
or you can look for reasons why you're right.
And,
and these things are happening.
And Solzhenitsyn talks a lot in the Gulag archipelago about,
see he had a moral condone drum when he was in prison.
And he started his moral awakening,
let's say.
And he was trying to figure out how to treat other people who were imprisoned.
He had a real moral conundrum when a committed communist was dragged into the
Gulag system,
which happened all the time.
He said those people were in particularly dire straits because not only had they
been subject to the entire tyrannical weight of the deceitful state,
but it was at the hands of their own comrades in France.
And then the,
the,
the committed communists would enter the Gulag and they would still be in there
morally superior phase,
right.
That,
that their incarceration was a mistake and that things would be set right and
that there was nothing wrong with the system and they would attempt to justify
it.
And Solzhenitsyn was no,
never sure how to react to these people ethically because on the one hand,
while they were,
you know,
devastated,
because now they were political prisoners and maybe they got a 20 year sentence
and they were in terrible.
You know,
stripped of their family and just ruined.
But on other hand,
they were still avid supporters of the very fist that had crushed them.
And so his eventual conclusion was that until they broke and repented they,
they weren't to be allied with,
they were still essentially on the side of the wall of the perpetrator.
And it seems to me that,
that,
that's right,
that's,
that's unrepentant sin,
let's say.
And it isn't till you,
what,
what would you say?
Until you take responsibility for your own complicitness in your,
in your unfair interrogation that you get to join the ranks of,
of,
of valuable in suffering humanity again.
And so,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's the extension of the persecution is really something that's horrifying to
see how,
who constituted a victimizer,
the ranks of who constituted victimizer just grew and grew and grew and grew.
One of the most shocking groups of people that ended up in the gulags were the
dam Soviet soldiers that had just got
back fighting.
Just Nazis.
You just can't,
you can't make up.
They can't make that up on getting soldier niche and who,
yeah.
Who was like in close combat with the enemy and he wrote a letter to one of his
buddies and said,
yeah,
this doesn't seem like to be a great decision by Stalin.
And next thing you know he's,
he's,
yeah,
yeah.
Well the stolen,
stolen decided that,
yeah,
this is something that you,
you,
you can't,
you can't believe this while it is,
there is this,
like,
it's like,
you know,
if there's something,
say titanic at the bottom of this,
you know,
mythologically speaking,
there's also something that's like a cosmic,
it's like cosmic black humor.
It's like the sign on Auschwitz that said work will set you free.
You know,
that's a joke,
right?
It's a whole,
it's a terrible,
terrible dark joke.
And so much of this has the element of,
of exactly that kind of surreal,
I hate to say humor,
but it's,
it's right.
I mean stolen decided that the,
okay,
so the Soviet prisoners of war were not covered by the Geneva Convention for the
treatment of prisoners of war.
Castelan re refused to sign that agreement.
So like if you were an allied prisoner of the Germans,
it wasn't like you were having a great time of it.
Like food was in short supply and you were treated pretty brutally.
But the Soviets were kept separately and they were doing so badly that the lis
used to throw food packets over the fence when that was an option.
So the Soviet prisoners of war were treated absolutely dreadfully and installing
didn't care about that.
Um,
and then when they were released and went back to the Soviet Union,
his dictum was that because they had been exposed to the capitalist West or even
the Nazi west for that matter,
that they had now been intolerably corrupted on ideological grounds and had to
be put in the prison camps.
So that was the,
that was your destiny,
as you know.
I mean,
first of all,
you were frontline Russian soldier,
which was just brutal beyond belief.
Their army was completely unprepared for Hitler's invasion because Stella and
trusted Hitler in his strange way.
And so they were completely unprepared.
And of course then fighting the Soviet Union with its winters.
I mean,
you just,
you just can't imagine what that must have been like.
And then to be thrown in a prisoner of war camp at the bottom of the rung and
then to be brought back to your country and then to be imprisoned as a trader
because as a class,
you'd been exposed to the wrong ideology.
It's like you just,
it's,
it's unimaginably vile and surreal at the same time.
And you shake your head for me,
while it's such a shock to read the Gulag archipelago,
it,
you just can't,
it's like a,
it is,
it's like Dante's inferno.
It's like a trip into hell.
Yeah.
And I guess your,
that's what I was trying to say when we,
when we started this,
does trying to say that it's like you're watching this,
uh,
like,
like you said,
it's like a bad comedy movie and you'd think,
well that's,
that'd be really that you'd think,
you know,
when you,
when you take a comedy,
well one of the things,
one of the ways you can make people laugh is to take something ordinary and
maybe make it much more extreme in the more extreme you make it,
the more funny it becomes.
That's what like happened here.
You're looking at this thing going,
hey,
oh yeah.
They seem to be trying to make this funny because who in could ever conceive
that you could take your front line soldiers who were captured and in misery and
when they return home instead of treating them like heroes,
instead you put them back into a prison.
Worst.
You can't even,
you can't even,
that's just,
that's it.
You can't make this stuff.
You can't make it up.
Nope.
Did you see,
I believe that movie was the death of Stalin did.
I did not see it.
But that's worth seeing
because it's,
it's very interesting because one of the things about that movie is that it
captures that surreal element because it's a black comedy,
you know,
and,
and there are comical things happening in the movie in that terrible dark way
constantly at the same time that in the background,
genuinely terrible things are happening.
So it's that horrible.
It's that it's,
it's got that horrible satirical flavor that runs through books like the Gulag
archipelago where you think,
well,
there's just no,
this is so absurd that there's no possible way it could have occurred.
And yet that's not only did it happen,
there was like a contest to talk to.
The absurdity,
you know,
to to,
to consider the engineers for example,
records is,
well these people were building the Soviet system to the degree that it was
built and then to turn around and accused exactly those people of being the ones
who destroy and undermine it.
It's,
it's part of,
I really think that what's what underlies this,
whatever this is,
and I think this is what manifests itself in the worst of the leftist.
Collectivism is a real hatred for anything that smacks of competence at all.
Like I,
I tried to imagine those Russian villages because I come from a small town,
a small northern town too.
So I kind of,
I tried to imagine,
so imagine that you're in an isolated village and um,
it's a peasant village and the peasants weren't fried that long ago,
right?
They were basically surfs until,
until about the middle of the second half of the 19th century.
And so they had been emancipated and in some of those people who are emancipated
guard a little bit of land and started to have a life,
you know,
started to be successful peasants and they were also the people that grew the
bulk of the crops.
Because what you see happening in any productive domain is that a small
percentage of people do almost all the productive work.
So there's a small percentage of productive farmers who grow all the crops,
right?
And then there's all sorts of farmers who were only farmers by name and they
weren't successful at all.
So you have,
and then there was a certain relationship between being productive as a farmer
and developing some wealth.
Maybe you had a house and maybe you could hire a person or two,
you know,
and which you'd think would be actually be a good thing,
especially if you are also growing food.
Okay?
So you imagine you,
you get a village and now there's a bit of a socioeconomic pyramid and there's
some people that are doing well and there are really and there and it isn't the
crooked people that are really annoying.
Then people who like the genuine Kulaks,
let's say that that small percentage of psychopathic types who were basically
profiting criminally off the efforts of others.
Those aren't so annoying.
Those people,
because they're rich,
but they don't deserve it.
And so they don't stand towards you as a moral ideal that shames you.
But the really annoying people are the ones who are doing well and deserve it,
especially if you're someone who's doing nothing and is bitter.
Okay?
So now,
so there's the village and you've got your people who are doing all right and
then you've got a huge Strout.
If people who aren't upset about the people who are doing well,
they might even admire them and be happy that they're around because they're
making the community thrive and growing some food.
Then you have this little,
this little,
uh,
strata at the bottom of people who are ne'er do wells and on the more
psychopathic end of things.
And they are bitter and resentful and,
and waiting for their bloody opportunity.
And then the communist intellectuals come into town and say,
you know,
those people that are doing well,
they actually,
everything they've got is ill gotten and they,
they,
they stole it and they stole it from you,
from you.
Like,
and look at how badly you're doing.
And the reason you're doing badly is because these,
these people who are lording it over you and who have all this creature comfort,
they took that from you.
It's yours by,
right?
And so then all that resentment and jealousy and hatred and rage,
alcohol fueled as you might well imagine,
has this moral reason to go with pitchforks and,
and in a mob and surround those houses and to strip them of everything they
have.
And to rape the women and to kill the occupants or to ship them off to the
middle of Siberia when there,
where they froze to death because there were no,
or died of dysentery or,
or,
or whatever other plague managed to,
you know,
weave its way through these camps.
And so you have the,
you have the intellectuals providing the moral rationale for the worst ethical
actors in these small villages doing the worst possible things under the guise
of compassion.
Right?
And that's part of that victim victimizer narrative.
It's just an Indian,
like you could imagine that you can imagine a dark night,
you can imagine the winter,
you can imagine the alcohol,
you can imagine the rage that fuels these people who are drinking too much in
the pubs that have been sitting there for the last 20 years.
Like,
what would you say?
Eating up their own souls with resentment and bitterness.
And then someone comes in and says,
you're the true victim here,
and here's the people that you can go after.
And then like,
if you play that on your imagination,
you get some real sense of exactly what sort of horror that would produce.
You know,
you think about the rape for example,
or,
or just the theft or,
but,
but it's the rape that you can really think about as,
as absolute revenge for all that bitter resentment.
All fueled by the fact that,
you know,
you'd sat there for the last 20 years being completely God damn useless and
bitter and,
and,
and angry and,
and fantasizing about the day that would come where you'd have your opportunity,
God and then the whole country,
then that was the whole country.
Oh,
it's just unbelievable.
Yeah.
And I think,
uh,
he,
he spells that out very clearly,
and he says,
you know what he's saying?
You know,
I'm saying that you got a psychopath and your platoon,
he saying that psychopath,
all that psychopath needs to flip is,
is the somewhat to tell them that that's the right thing to do.
And that's exactly what happened.
What'd you say?
That,
that's it?
But those guys that were slightly psychopathic,
yeah.
And then it becomes,
okay,
I'm the,
I'm the head psychopath and you're in my village and you're,
let's say you're one of those people that are in the middle.
Well,
whose side are you gonna be on?
I'm a psychopath.
If you,
if you're not on my side,
I'm going to kill you next.
So you go,
well,
no,
I'm on your side too.
And that's definitely
doesn't take a look.
It's not like it takes much pressure
on people to have them fold.
I mean,
one of the things you see,
you see happening right now in our cultures that's happening to people all the
time with these Twitter wars.
You know,
someone will say something,
they'll express an opinion and then they'll get mobbed by and,
but only abstractly.
Right?
It's not like there's pitchfork wielding mobs at their house and then I'm not
making light of it.
It's,
no,
it's no pleasant thing to be mobbed on Twitter,
but that's,
that's an obstruction compared to these people showing up at your house,
you know?
And,
yeah,
and what'll happen is that people will go through an abject apology,
you know,
and they'll say,
well,
I really didn't mean it.
And,
and now I understand what my privilege is and I see how what I said could have
been very hurtful to people.
And you know,
they,
they wonder through that entire apology and fold almost instantly.
And,
and that's under almost,
almost no pressure compared to what real pressure is.
Real pressure is when the wolves are actually at your door rather than just
barking off in the distance.
But people will fold just when they're barking in the distance.
So
there's one lawyer that he talks about in here is the same thing as the story
that new scribing,
I forget the guy's name,
but this guy was like the premier prosecuting lawyer for the Soviet government
and he just rips people apart over and over again.
And as you read about what happened to him,
sure enough,
he's,
one of the guys had been ended up on the,
on the defensive and Yam being executed.
Yeah.
Like they have all these things,
these,
well they
built,
they built,
uh,
um,
a place of butchery and then threw themselves into it.
You know,
that's,
and,
and you see Solzhenitsyn documents this very carefully.
I mean,
Stalin killed all the people who,
who were foremost actors in the Russian revolution,
right?
So,
I mean,
everyone was fed into the great grinding machine.
So,
and,
and Stalin himself,
I mean,
it looked to me like,
see,
he got himself into something approximating a positive feedback loop,
which is a very dangerous thing to have happen.
And I think Solzhenitsyn does a lovely job of detailing this as well.
So it's like,
imagine that I have a fair amount of contempt for people to begin with.
And then I find that people are,
I'm not trusting person.
And I find that I,
I'm very paranoid about the fact that people are lying to me and then I develop
a certain amount of power and a reputation.
Well then people really do start lying to me all the time in every gesture,
you know,
because every time they come near me,
they're absolutely terrified and they're going to tell me anything that I want
to hear.
And of course then all that does is validate my view of how pathetic and
contemptible everyone is and so on.
The more that view gets validated,
the more I think that it's okay to destroy people.
Because look at how pathetic and contemptible they are,
how they always lie.
And all that means is that they lie even more.
And so this whole thing just spirals out of control.
And you know,
Stellan basically started out as a,
as the brutal enforcement henchmen for henchmen,
for Lennon,
right?
The,
the,
the killer for hire.
And not like Lennon was above that sort of thing himself,
but he trained Stalin and,
and then Stalin's proclivity to be murderous,
just kept expanding without limit,
right?
First of all,
it was individuals and then it was groups and then it was nations.
And then,
well,
by the end of his life,
what was it,
the plot,
the plot to destroy the entire world.
Tu Tu,
Tu Tu Tu initiate the Third World War to wipe out Europe to maybe destroy
everything and like there's no limit.
There was no limit to that,
you know?
And there's some evidence that that's perhaps why he was killed,
you know,
because Stalin himself even went too far for the horrible,
for the horrible,
um,
what semi
the,
the corrupted compadres that he had,
he'd arranged around himself.
He went too far even for them.
And,
and thank God for that,
you know?
But yeah,
it's,
it's absolute,
I mean,
the thing that,
that the Gulag Archipelago Gulag archipelago did for me,
and this was also in keeping as a consequence,
also have reading young at the same time,
but,
but it was certainly the go light in,
in large part that did it.
I would say that in some sense it's scared me straight.
I thought.
I see the,
the consequences of unethical behavior,
deceit,
the willingness to,
to turn a blind eye.
So even sins of omission rather than sins of commission just to turn a blind
eye.
The consequences of that are so absolutely dreadful that it's not acceptable.
And I think that's the right lesson from the 20th century.
It's that,
ew,
ew.
You have a much more moral role to play in keeping things straight.
Then you want to believe,
you know,
people think,
well,
my life is basically meaningless.
It's like,
well that's quite terrifying.
yeah,
it's kind of terrifying,
but it means you don't have any responsibility.
So there's a big advantage to thinking that,
you know,
not if nothing you do matters,
then nothing you do matters.
And so you can do whatever you want and,
and that's horrifying and annihilistic sort of way.
But there's another kind of horror that's more associated,
I think with the horror of hell fire that was characteristic of the Medieval
Christian view is,
which is something like if you strip it of its metaphysics,
it's something like,
no,
you don't get it.
The things you do actually do the things you do or don't do,
they actually do matter.
And they tilt the world towards,
you know,
something approximating good,
let's say,
or towards something that very closely approximates hell and that's actually on
you.
It's literally your fault.
It's literally your responsibility.
It's like,
man,
that's a terrifying,
that's a terrifying idea.
But I can't see how you can read this literature without coming to that
conclusion.
Like it wasn't one that I wanted to leap to.
You know,
it's like it's,
it's,
it's sort of the ultimate in horrifying conclusions that,
that everybody who participated in this system was at fault for all of it.
And on Dostoyevsky made the same sorts of claims in,
in,
in the last part of the 19th century.
I mean,
he was a very weird,
mystical sort of person,
you know,
and he,
he made claims are some of his characters did,
but on his behalf that,
you know,
not only are you responsible for everything you do,
but in some sense you're responsible for everything that everyone else does too.
And you think,
well,
obviously there's a way in which that isn't true.
You know,
it's delusional in some sense.
But there's another way in which it actually is true.
You know?
And so
I wrote a book called extreme ownership and it's,
it's very inner.
So all,
so all this,
is this like a whole thought here.
So,
you know,
when I read the book about face,
which is not about leadership,
it's not a leadership book,
it's a,
it's a book about a guy that was in the leadership position,
but he doesn't say,
here's how you lead,
here's what you do here.
It's a book about his experience and what I took away from it,
especially because I was in leadership positions in the military in combat
situations that I started seeing all these leadership things that he did.
And there's all this crossover because for instance,
and so for me the crossover was while I started learning about tactics when I
was a young kid,
cause I was in the military and the seal teams and you had to learn about how to
fire and maneuver.
Like that's what you do.
And then so you start learning about leadership.
And then I started training a lot of Jujitsu and so,
so those things kind of all fit together.
And it's very strange how those things started to weave together in my head
that,
oh,
if
on the battlefield,
if you want to attack the enemy,
you don't do it head on you,
you flank them,
you distract them in,
then you flank him,
you come in from the outside.
In Jujitsu,
if you want to submit your opponent,
you,
you don't grab their arm.
No,
you start to choke them and while they're defending the choke,
then you get their arm.
And as a leader,
if you want somebody to do something,
you just don't bark that order at them.
You flank them and you let them understand why it's happening.
And,
and you know,
when I started this podcast that I do,
I would say I started off by saying in the beginning,
I'd say that's a podcast about leadership viewed through the Lens of war and
atrocity.
And the more I did it and it didn't take me very long where I was saying,
well it's,
it's actually a podcast about human nature really is what it's actually about.
Because the better you understand human beings,
the better you'll be able to do as a leader because you'll understand what's
happening with those dynamics,
which I guess is now leading me into some sort of psychology.
You would just kind of where you ended up with them.
Have you read this book and you said you were studying political science when
you read this book and then you said,
oh,
you looked at the psychology of it and see an example that you just brought up.
And this is just what you learn when you read and when you understand history
and when you understand the way people think stolen,
surrounded himself with people that would say yes to him and anybody that didn't
say yes to him,
he killed them.
And I'll say this again,
I'll talk to military identity also killed you if you said yes.
Yeah,
the uh,
the,
I'll talk to military for sure,
but also any business leader.
We talked to business leaders all the time,
and you don't want people,
you don't want your subordinates or your superiors when you tell them what to
do,
to just nod their head and said,
yes,
you don't want that.
Now the,
the,
the immediate thought,
especially for a military guy,
they think they're nothing would make my job easier then if I bark in order it,
you,
Jordan,
you work from Europe,
private and Naama captain and I barked an order.
You,
you just shut up and go do it.
And that seems like the best thing in the world.
It's absolutely not true because there's things that,
you know,
on the front lines that I don't know.
And if I really want to be a good leader,
I want you to push back on me and say,
Hey boss,
we don't want to do that.
Here's what's going on.
Let me tell you the situation.
And instead of making,
you want to be able to do that,
you want to be able to teach your subordinates to do that without being
insubordinate.
Right?
Cause then it's not a power play.
It's that your,
your interests are aligned.
Our interests are aligned.
And I actually,
when I talked to the subordinates,
cause I talked to subordinates to yeah.
And I say,
listen,
when you say something to your boss,
you don't say,
why the hell are we doing that boss?
You actually have to be very tactful DSS.
Exactly.
Hey,
hey,
hey boss,
I want to make sure I'm executing this exactly how you want it.
Can you explain to me why we're doing this?
So I can really,
really make it happen out there in the field.
And that's a key thing.
So,
so these ideas of,
of,
you know,
psychology I guess now as,
I hate to use that word,
but because I was just calling me human nature,
but these ideas,
they all kind of come together.
And so now you're talking about
ownership,
right?
Extreme ownership and this idea that hey,
I'm responsible for everything.
And so here's what I'll get from a leader.
They'll say,
well,
whether it's a business leader or it's,
it's very easy to use a military leader,
so I'll get a platoon commander,
my machine gun,
or shot in the wrong direction.
How can that be my fault because my machine got a shot in the regression?
I'm not,
I'm not holding his weapon.
I'm not pulling his from from,
how can that possibly be my fault?
That's not my fault.
[inaudible] wrong.
Who's in charge of that machine gun?
Who's in charge of making sure he understands what his fields of fire,
who's in charge of making sure he understands when and where he's allowed to
shoot you are.
You're the boss.
This is absolutely your fault.
Had another interesting example of the weather.
The weather's bad.
We couldn't execute our mission.
That's why we failed because we couldn't launch our helicopters.
It's not my fault.
That's a hard one to argue against except for the fact that if you're a good
leader,
you'll say,
hey,
here's our plan.
We're going to use these helicopters and here's our contingency plan.
If there's bad weather,
if you don't take that ownership of what's going on,
if you don't take responsibility for it,
you're not going to change it.
You're not going to fix it.
And that means you're never getting any better.
You're not going to win.
Right.
But the minute you as,
and this,
and obviously this applies to you know,
people to purple,
then you know,
you tell people to take responsibility.
I've,
you know,
tell him,
take ownership of what's going on in your world.
It's this,
it's the same thing,
but
well,
it's also,
it's also seems to me to be the case.
And I think that this is part of the ethic that's embedded in,
in,
it's deeply embedded in Christianity with the idea that
the idea that the ultimate sacrifice that you can offer to the world is the
sacrifice of yourself.
It's like,
well,
imagine that you have to sacrifice something to set the world right while you
do,
obviously,
because you have to give up things now in order to make things better in the
future.
So the sacrificial ideas,
a very deep one,
then the question might be,
well,
if you're going to sacrifice something,
is it going to be someone else or is it going to be you?
And I really think that's the fundamental question and the right answer to that
is that it's going to be you.
It's your fault,
right?
You take that on,
or at least you take on that responsibility.
And it is,
it's a weird thing.
Weird Lee,
difficult to distinguish fault and responsibility.
I think responsibility is the better way of thinking about it,
but it's tied in with the idea of fault.
If it doesn't go right,
if it isn't going right,
it's because you're not good enough.
Now that can be crushing.
There is a problem with that.
Like,
and you see sometimes people who develop like psychotic depression and they,
um,
they,
they suffer from a delusional condition in some sense that the entire moral
catastrophe of the world is literally their fault.
And that's not there.
There's an element of that that's,
that's not productive.
Although there's a truth in it as well,
you know?
And,
and it's hard to,
it's hard to find the balance so that you can take on that responsibility
without simultaneously being a crushing weight because there's a lot of things
in the world that are really not good.
And if they're your fault,
well that's rather hard on you.
I mean,
one of the things that the Catholic church does to help people with that is that
it gives them the opportunity to be sort of wash their sins off themselves,
right?
You can go to church and you can say,
well,
look,
here's a bunch of ways that I've been being not who I could be.
And the Church authorities say,
well,
you know,
that's not good and you should straighten up and all of that and fly,
right?
But human beings are fallible and you're fallible and,
and,
and we can't just crush you because of your insufficiency.
So we'll wash the slate clean and you can go out there and try again.
And it's very hard to get the balance between those things,
right?
So that you can take the responsibility on without being crushed by it,
but,
but it's still the case that it seems to me that it's either your fault or it's
someone else's and as soon as it's someone else's,
then you better be careful because that idea that it's someone else's is
definitely going to appeal to the worst in you.
That's definitely going to happen and if you don't see that,
then you're naive or willfully blind and,
and all that is going to do all that.
All that that is going to do is make the situation worse.
Yeah.
Especially because if it's not my fault and it's your fault and I can't control
you,
what do I do about it?
I sit there and just suffer the consequences of the situation as opposed to,
okay,
here's what's going on.
I'm going to take responsibility and ownership for it.
I'm going to change it,
make it happen.
You talked about turning a blind died and earlier you talked about turning a
blind eye to the truth to a situation.
And I know there's a point in this book where he talks about,
he's got a buddy that says,
amnesty is coming,
right?
Amnesty is coming.
Let's just keep our mouth shut.
Let's do what we're told to do and we'll get,
you know,
we'll get out.
Amazon's coming.
And you know,
Solzhenitsyn says,
he saying,
okay,
yeah.
And then he says to himself,
wait a minute,
if I'm not,
if I'm not living in order to live,
then is it worth it?
And this is a question that I get asked a lot because people get themselves into
situations
where they've lost some kind of control,
whether it's they're in a crappy job or they've got a bad boss or whatever.
Maybe they're in a bad relationship,
maybe their families met,
but they're,
they're in a situation and they,
and they don't know what to do.
And part of them,
I think anticipates the answer from me to be,
listen,
Hey,
if you're not,
if you're not living in order to live,
then that's wrong.
But what I actually tell them universally almost,
and there was a couple situations where it goes outside this,
but it's like that.
What I tell them is what you need to do right now is you need to play the game.
You need to play the game to get this situation to a point where you can act,
right?
So if you're,
you've got a bad boss,
right?
Yep.
Oh,
you okay?
You got to buy Boston.
I want to tell this guy to go screw himself and he's,
hey,
guess what I'm going to do when my boss tells me something to do that it doesn't
make much sense.
You know what I'm gonna do?
I'm gonna do it and I'm going to do it well,
and what am I doing on building that relationship with him?
He starting to trust me and he's gonna tell me to do something else.
Now these things are massive cutoffs catastrophes.
It's like he's telling me to do something.
Maybe there's a better way to do it.
You don't even know how to do it that way.
And I'm going to play that game and I'm going to build up that relationship.
Now when eventually he tells me to do something that is totally stupid or it's
going to cost,
you know,
lives or money.
Then when I say,
hey boss,
that's not a great way to do it.
I think I know a better way.
Can we try something else?
He actually will listen to me.
So I'm going to play the game a little bit and I'll tell you my gut instinct.
If now I guess it's,
it's easy to look from the outside and say,
hey,
if I was in this prison camp,
my gut instinct is like,
okay,
Jack would,
you know,
you've been through these kinds of things before,
play the game,
you're going to play the game,
which is horrifying because part of playing that game to the fullest extent here
or in a Nazi prison camp would be coming to capitol.
Oh,
you're playing the game.
You're playing the game.
Yeah.
So,
and that's really the outlying,
the things that I said that our outlying,
I always make the caveat that if you're getting asked to do something that's
immoral,
illegal or unethical,
then you actually have a duty to say,
no,
I'm not going to do that.
No,
that's,
that's the line which you know,
which you reach that line in the sand with a bill,
see 16 which is,
hey,
I'm not going to do this.
But the idea that sometimes you got to play the game and sometimes even from
you,
when you just said to me,
he said,
well,
you know,
sometimes it's not right to turn a blind eye on things.
And it's like
sometimes you have to,
if you want to get yourself to a position like my s my,
it seems to me
that you're making a distinction between discipline and strategy,
like and,
and,
and like impulsive,
moral responding.
You know,
like let's say that you are in a situation where you have a boss who's
intolerable and maybe what you'd like to do,
you know,
the resentment has built up over five years and you'd like to go in there and,
and yell at him and tell him everything you think and you think,
well that's the truth.
It's like,
well,
it's actually,
it's not a very sophisticated truth because you're doing as shallow and
impulsive analysis of the situation.
Like it would have been the case that you've already compromised yourself in 500
ways.
And I'll get back to the playing the game issue because you do have to
discipline yourself to,
and you have to discipline yourself to,
to some degree,
by allowing yourself to do arbitrary things that are part of the system,
right?
That's a necessary part of discipline.
And discriminating that from a compliance with unethical activity is very
difficult.
So that's a hard situation.
But let's say you're,
you're,
you're going to counsel someone who has an intolerable boss and they come in and
they're right at the end of their tether because maybe that's why they come for
counseling.
They say,
I really want to tell that son of a bitch.
What I think of it,
man.
You think,
well,
wait a second here.
Okay,
first of all,
you've already eradicated from the list of reasonable possibilities.
That decision by failing to say small things that you could have said all the
way along and it's not like you can just all of a sudden blurt all of that out
now and that wipes the slate clean in.
That constitutes truth.
It's too unsophisticated.
So let's think,
okay,
so what is it that you want?
Well,
I don't want this job anymore.
It's like,
okay,
now let,
let's actually have a strategy about this.
Then you don't want this job anymore.
Can you get another job?
While I don't think so.
Well,
so you can't just quit.
no I can't because then I don't have any money in my family.
Depends on the job.
It's like,
okay,
so you can't just stop.
This does,
that's not a viable solution.
You go out of the frying pan into the fire or you know,
you suck you s you substitute one set of unethical actions for another set of
unethical actions that are even worse.
That's not helpful.
All right,
so let's start thinking about what exactly it is that you want.
It's like,
well,
maybe I want a better job.
I want to work for someone who is more reasonable.
Okay,
so what's stopping you?
Well,
I don't have my CV in order.
My resume isn't up to date.
Well,
why is that?
I haven't done it for five years and I don't like doing it.
Well,
why is that?
because I'm kind of embarrassed about it because it has holes in it and it shows
where I'm lackadaisical and where I'm not prepared.
It's like,
okay,
how many things are there like that?
Well,
there's a bunch of things and they're all associated with how I procrastinated
in the past.
It's like,
okay,
what are we going to do to rectify that?
So I'll say to people,
why don't you update your CV that that's what we'll do first.
Because if you're going to look for a different job,
I'm not saying you're going to look for a different job,
but if you're going to look for a different job,
you're not going to,
unless your cvs updated,
so don't you go unless you can get a good recommendation from this boss that's a
tyrant.
That's right.
There's you to play the care's tennis strategic actions that you're going to
have to take in order to make yourself able to move laterally or up and the
truth is isn't going in and yelling at your boss and telling him everything you
think about it.
The truth is trying to figure out the very,
very difficult process of how you put yourself in a better position and that
that are like,
one of the things that's quite fun about this lecture tour is the letters that I
receive or the stories that people tell me about switching jobs because they do
realize that there,
and I often talk to people about consulting their resentment.
Resentments are really useful emotion,
like it's really dangerous.
It's one of the most dangerous psychological states,
I believe.
But it's unbelievably useful because resentment usually only means one of two
things.
It either means quit whining and,
and take it on because you're immature or it means you're allowing yourself to
be taken advantage of and you have something to say or do.
And so you want to sort out the first part and find out if you're just being
immature and you can think that through and you can talk to people.
Um,
but,
and then,
but if it's the second,
it's like,
no,
you've compromised yourself in a variety of ways and you have to figure out how
to get out of that.
And if you're resentful,
that's evidence that you have in fact done that.
Okay.
So now that issue would be,
well,
how can you set your life up so that you can be without that resentment?
And so that's when you start to develop a strategy for,
you know,
and,
and it,
there's actually an adventure in this too.
I mean,
I've had a number of clients who have been in jobs that they didn't like it all.
And you know,
they were tyrannized by someone for example,
and they were also working below their hypothetical level and we'd put together
a plan.
It's like,
okay,
you're going to make three times as much money in five years.
That's the plan.
But like that's not going to be simple.
So there's education.
You gotta educate yourself,
maybe formerly cause you've got holes,
you got to fix up your resume,
you've got to,
you've got to overcome your fear of being interviewed.
You have to start sending out like 50 resumes a week on a regular basis and be
prepared for a 99% rejection rate.
You,
you're going to look for different job.
It's probably going to take six months to a year and almost all of that is going
to be rejection.
And you got to steel yourself from for that and prepare.
And maybe this is going to be a three year process.
It's no trivial thing.
But you know,
it's almost inevitably can't remember a single example where the consequence of
that very careful,
detailed,
strategic thinking wasn't a massively substantive improvement in socioeconomic
positioning and a great movement towards,
uh,
an improving trajectory.
And,
and,
and there's advantages even along the way because even before that happens,
the fact that you're taking genuine steps to put yourself in a better situation
immediately starts to reduce your resentment,
even if it isn't having positive consequences to begin with.
But you have to be realistic about it.
It's like,
look,
it's going to be hard to update your CV because you're embarrassed about it and
you should be right.
It's no wonder you're embarrassed about it.
And then,
well,
of course you don't want to go be interviewed because you're not very good at it
and,
and there's holes in your story and,
and your,
and you can be made nervous easily and you're not a very good advocate for
yourself.
So there's a lot of improvement that needs to be done there.
And,
uh,
and then you have to withstand the,
the,
the punishment of being constantly rejected when you apply for jobs.
Because the baseline rejection rate,
you know,
for the,
for the typical job,
applicant is like 99%.
It's like the rejection rate for everything.
Is this going to work?
No.
But if you do it a hundred times,
it might work once.
That's all you need.
That's exactly it.
It,
you,
you only need that once.
And so the truth there isn't to yell at your boss.
The truth there is to get your life together.
Yeah.
Um,
play the game.
You gotta play the game sometimes too to get a strategic win to me.
And that's,
and another interesting thing here is,
as I say,
you don't want to surround yourself with yes men.
When you're in a leadership position,
you also don't want to be your own personal yes ma'am.
That he just thinks you're great and agrees with everything that you're doing
and,
and won't tell yourself the hard truth.
You know,
you can't lie to yourself.
Everything.
Every little one of those things that you've just listed off are the kinds of
things that people just lie to themselves and say,
ah,
you know what?
Well,
you don't really need that.
That person didn't learn anything in that,
in that course.
Why should I go to it?
That you know,
it's like if you don't tell yourself the truth about what your,
what your situation is,
it's going to be problematic.
Just like if you don't have people on your team above you or below you in the
chain of command that tell you the truth,
that's going to be problematic as well,
which is something which is something that's easier.
So the playing the game thing.
So are you thinking about that as a consequence of necessary discipline?
You know like cause cause there,
because it,
it seems to be you're making two cases at the same time,
right?
One is that you should obviously not undertake unethical actions,
but then by the same token and you have to subordinate yourself to the realities
of the situation.
And,
and I think that that's psychologically true because you're always in a
situation where if you're in an organization,
there's kind of an arbitrary and tyrannical aspect to it because it's never
working perfectly.
And then,
and then there's the,
the positive aspect to it too.
And so whenever you're doing a job,
it could be that you're,
you're called upon to do things that well,
what would you say that are unnecessary part of the operation of the machinery?
I guess that would be particularly true in military.
Every situations.
And,
and let me give you these as well.
Just a broad example,
right?
Um,
you know,
my personality and my reputation is that,
when I was in the military,
it's like,
oh,
it's Jocko.
He,
he's not gonna,
you know,
he's,
if,
if someone tells him to do something he doesn't want to do,
he's just going to say,
screw you.
We're not doing it.
We're doing it my way.
You know?
Um,
I got the knock.
But that was kind of the impression people would get from me.
If they didn't know me from the outside,
they think,
oh,
this guy's a knuckle dragger he's just going to go forward.
He,
he's going to make things happen and he's not going to listen to anyone else.
That was the impression from the outside.
The reality is you can't do that and,
and be the reality is w w what my actions are,
I'd have,
you know,
a young lieutenant would come to me and say,
Hey,
you know,
my boss has to tell me to do this,
this and this.
And what they think I was going to say is like,
Bro,
you don't do that.
Stand up and you tell them,
screw you,
that doesn't make any sense.
And they'd be,
they'd get this look in their eyes of,
of surprise when I'd say,
oh,
your boss wants you to do that.
Do it,
do it.
Well,
play the game.
That's what I'm telling you to do is play the game because these things are
meaningless.
It's some,
you know,
something is pathetic.
It's like,
oh you got to fill out a form a certain way.
Hey,
shut up and play the game.
You'll look even my,
so is that a matter matter of picking your battles?
It's,
it certainly is a matter of picking your battles and you as cause that's part of
strategy,
right?
It's everything can't be the war.
Exactly.
And it's exactly what it is.
But you know,
a good example,
and we wrote about it in,
in a dichotomy of leadership,
which is,
you know,
my friend,
my guy that worked for me,
Leif Babin,
we were getting told to do all this paperwork.
You gotta,
you gotta fill out these forms.
You've got to,
you got to have a serialized inventory of everything.
It's got to be signed off this many days.
We need to know the qualifications of each and every person and when their
qualifications come up,
do and all these just ridiculous paperwork.
And Lafe came to me and with,
with the other platoon commander guy named Seth,
he came to me and said,
Oh man,
this is bullshit.
Why do we gotta do all this paperwork where we are here training for war,
we're getting ready for war.
Why we got to do this?
And you know,
life will tell you his expectation was that I was going to be like,
you're right,
I'm going to go to the commanding officer and tell him,
screw this.
We're not doing this stuff.
This is crap.
We're trying to prepare because we were in training,
getting ready to deploy to Iraq.
This is crap.
We're not doing this.
And I looked at him and said,
oh,
we're doing all of this paperwork and not only are we going to do this
paperwork,
we're going to do it better than anyone else and we're going to turn it in
before it's even do.
And you know,
we both him and Seth were kind of taken a back then the fact that I wasn't
standing up and saying,
we're not doing this,
our APP.
And then I explained to me,
here's what we're doing.
We're building a relationship with my commanding officer,
with a our commanding officer.
We're going to do these little things for him.
We're going to play the game because at some 0.2 things are gonna happen.
Number one,
we want to build trust with my boss.
I want my boss to look at me and when he tells me to do it,
to fill out paperwork,
he knows is going to be filled out.
If he wants me to take down a building,
he knows it's going to get taken out.
If he wants me to execute a larger mission,
I'll go and get it done.
Where if I can't fill out paperwork correctly,
how can he trust me to go on and on a real operation and have guys lives at
risk?
So the idea is like,
hey,
we're gunna play the game.
And I think sometimes people start to hear me,
they start to listen to me and their first instinct is Jocko wouldn't put up
with them shit.
And that's why these,
you know,
they'll hit me up the same thing.
They'll write me an email,
they'll write me a letter and say,
here's the situation I'm in.
Um,
whether it's a boss,
whether it's a military,
it's,
it's any of them,
whether it's their wife,
like,
like my wife expects me not to train Jujitsu.
It's something as stupid as that.
Like my wife won't let me train.
It's driving me crazy.
It's really starting to bother me.
Why?
Why won't you?
Well,
what's the problem?
Hey,
have you taken her out for dinner?
You know what I mean?
Like play the damn game a little bit so that you can win strategic.
And it's the same thing I think with your,
with the 12 rules where you're like,
hey,
tell the truth,
or at least don't lie.
It's like I get it.
But there's a dichotomy in that statement and that is if you run around telling
the absolute truth,
everyone,
it's going to be like that Jim Carey movie where he can't say anything that's
not a hundred percent true.
And he's,
you know,
got a woman says good morning and he says,
you look fat.
You know what I mean?
It's like one of those like that marine not good.
And so you got to learn to play the game.
And I guess again,
going back to this book,
it's like that's a tough call to make in these situations.
How much do you play the game?
And there's an ethical line that you could cross at some point if I become a
cappo,
hey,
you just,
you played the game and you went too far with it.
And just like in a leadership situation,
if I,
if you're my boss and I'm just kissing your ass and do one under every t,
my guys lose respect for me.
Yeah,
my team will lose respect from me if you tell me to do something completely
stupid and I say,
hey guys,
that's what the boss says,
we're doing it.
My guys will lose respect for me and I won't be,
I won't be able to execute missions the way I should.
If when the pushback is proper,
I say,
hey,
Hey Boston,
that doesn't make any sense.
We shouldn't do that.
And I go to the guys and say,
listen,
I told,
I talked to him,
we're going to see what he says,
but trust me,
if we have to do this,
we'll,
we'll figure out a way to make it work.
Because if you're just the guy that's totally on board.
If you're a brown noser right,
your P,
your guys will lose respect for you 100% they will.
They will lose respect for you if you don't play the game at all and you'd push
back on everything that your boss says you're going to,
you're not going to get fire.
Yeah.
That's another ethical situation.
Like if my,
if you're my boss and you told me to do something that's I don't believe in or
it's like a bad plan and I may I draw the line in the sand and say,
screw you Jordan,
we're not doing it.
You can fire me.
You're like,
okay,
fine,
you fire me.
You get some yes man to come in.
He takes my guys out on the mission and gets them all killed.
He didn't mitigate the risk properly.
It's better for me ethically to say,
hey look Jordan,
I don't agree with this plan.
I really wish we could do it another way.
Is there any way I could flex on it?
You say,
nope,
you're doing it this way.
It is better for me in many situations to say,
okay,
I got it.
I'll make it happen.
Indication of the complexity of the truth.
I mean,
one of the rules of thumb that I think is worth abiding by,
and I guess this is something that makes me somewhat conservative in some ways,
is that you should do what everyone else does unless there's a very good reason
not to.
And then I think that's,
I think that's the same idea that you're putting forward,
which is that if you,
if you do fight back against everything,
then you're just a rebel without a cause.
Right?
And you and you discredit yourself entirely.
And if you accept everything,
well then you're not even there.
And so there's some judicious and analysis of the situation that helps you
understand when the time for action is right.
And most of the time what you're doing in life is you're doing what other people
do and that's going along with the game.
That's part of being socialized.
But there's going to be times when the right thing to do is to break a rule and
to do it very carefully.
And so,
and if there's a,
there's a,
there's a scene,
I think this is a new testament scene,
but it might be in some of the Apocryphal,
right?
Apocryphal writings.
I don't remember.
So Christ is walking down the road on
the Sabbath and there's,
uh,
there's a ditch by the road and it's very hot.
And in the ditch there's a whole,
and in the whole there's a sheep.
And so the sheep is stuck in the hole.
And this Guy Shepherd is trying to get the sheep out of the hall.
And Christ walks by and he says,
if you don't understand what you're doing,
you're a transgressor of the law and your curse.
But if you do understand what you're doing,
then you're blessed.
So it's,
it's,
it's a perfect example of that.
A,
because it's,
it's like if you're okay,
now here's your situation.
You're a shepherd and you're supposed to be taken care of that sheep,
right?
But it's the Sabbath Day.
So you're not supposed to be work.
Now,
if you have decided you've thought this through,
you think it's the Sabbath Day.
This is something that everybody needs because everybody needs to take a rest.
And this is a rule I shouldn't break because everybody needs to take a rest or
or things degenerate.
And I understand that and I have a lot of respect for it.
But I think that in this situation it's still morally appropriate for me to
break that rule in this slight way and get this poor sheep out of this hole then
well,
Christ's judgment was,
well then you're exactly on the right track.
But if you're doing it carelessly and stupidly,
you're breaking that rule,
then we are a transgressor of the law.
And you're cursed.
And I think that's exactly at the essence of what you're describing.
It's like you play by the rules,
but then there's a Meta rule which is now,
and then you break the rules and you do that very,
very carefully because when you break the rules,
you're breaking the rules.
And the rules are what keep peace.
They,
they're what keep peace in order.
And so you break them only in the service of a higher piece in order.
And so that seems to be,
and I think that's,
you see this in in well,
this sorts of stories that are influencing even the things that you're writing.
Like in the Harry Potter series,
for example,
Harry's,
um,
friends and compatriots are quite disciplined.
Her Maya and he in particular,
cause she's an absolute master of her craft,
but they still break rules when it's necessary,
only when it's necessary.
And that's what makes them more than the people who are just breaking rules all
the time.
The villains,
so to speak,
and also makes them more than the people that are just being good by being
conformist.
So you need that,
that touch of rebellious nus,
but it's gotta be a flavoring and not the whole diet.
Absolutely.
I've actually talked about that on this podcast before.
There's people in the military that they are like,
men are rule followers.
These are people that have been following rules their whole lives and they've
got perfect grades and they were,
the team came,
they were all of these things and they're,
they're going to make really good solid leaders.
Like they're going to be great leaders.
But then there's this like one group above them have that same thing,
but they also have that little bit of rebellion that they'll say,
you know what,
we're not doing that.
It doesn't make any sense.
And that is really a uh,
uh,
an important factor to have.
Yeah.
But you know,
that's one of the reasons I would like this Guy Colonel David Hackworth,
this guy was the ultimate rule follower for his whole career at the end in
Vietnam,
he did an interview and said,
if we keep fighting this way,
we're not going to win this war.
And they drove him out of the army.
But that's,
that's the thing that,
cause all along the way,
there was other times where he do that,
you know,
his guys weren't getting taken care of.
He'd break a rule and bring them beer or he did you know,
he didn't he do that along the way.
Not,
not so far outside the bonds that it would jeopardize his career.
Because if he would do that,
then you're not in charge of these guys anymore.
Now you're not going to have any impact in there.
So let's not get fired.
Right,
right.
Let's not get stupidly fired.
That's not an improvement.
Exactly.
Well that's uh,
awesome.
Uh,
I guess we,
I know you've got to go,
so I can't think that we could get to a better little crust of the other or
little capstone of the conversation then.
Right there.
Uh,
thanks for coming on again.
Hey,
my pleasure man.
I'm glad we got a chance to talk about this book.
This is a book that everybody should read and you,
I ordered the,
well,
I ordered a copy of yours with the Ford from Europe.
You can't buy it from Amazon here.
You have to buy it from Amazon.
So it will be here.
When will it be?
I don't know.
We're still negotiating the rights because the rights holders differ in North
America and so that's the issue at the moment.
So,
okay.
So I worked with an English publisher,
Penguin in,
in the UK that that put out the,
I think it's vantage books,
if I remember correctly.
I should just check and make sure that that's exactly right.
Harper perennial modern classics.
That's not,
that's not the British won the British.
The British one hasn't gotten to my house.
Yeah.
It has to be ordered.
It has to be ordered through Amazon UK.
And we're,
we're working on a couple of things maybe to also maybe get the audio rights to
the abridged version because I'd like to read it nice.
And that would be good so that people could listen to it.
And so because it's,
it's an absolutely necessary book.
Yeah.
And it's written actually.
What's,
I like it cause it's written very conversation.
I mean he's cracking jokes in there and he's making,
it's a brilliant piece of literature as well as,
I mean it's a very readable book,
although it's unbelievably harsh and demanding and draining to read.
But it's,
it's brilliantly written.
It's an unbelievably engrossing read in,
in the most horrible possible way.
But,
and it is the case that it's written at this white hot pace.
You know,
it's like talking to someone who's righteously,
not self righteously angry,
but righteously angry for,
for,
for dozens of hours.
And he just can't believe the levels of outrage that are,
that are being,
that are being so incredibly well expressed and so effectively expressed.
And,
and,
and again,
I,
I think it's also worth emphasizing the fact that,
you know,
Solzhenitsyn's real contribution in many ways was to lay the catastrophe at the
feet of the doctrine and not to say no,
this,
this wasn't an aberration because of Stella North in Oh,
Lennon being the great leader and then Stella and being the monster because
Lennon was plenty monster himself.
Um,
and Stellan was the logical conclusion to lend and not,
not an aberration,
but to say that no,
the horrors of what happened in the Soviet Union were,
were implicit in the collectivists system utopian system that gave rise to the
philosophy to begin with.
And that that's also an explanation why the same catastrophes occurred wherever
the Soviet system was applied everywhere else in the world at something we
really need to know.
I mean,
we fought a whole cold war over that.
We put damn near put the world to the torch because of this.
And the idea that these ideas are the fact that these ideas are creeping back.
It's really,
it's unbearable as far as I'm concerned.
So we'll hopefully people reading this book and the,
the rerelease of this book with your forward will prevent that from happening.
At least hopefully it will be a drop in a bucket that many other people can put
drops into as well.
And so I'm hoping,
I mean,
I think the book has sold 15,000 copies since the beginning of November,
which is pretty good for the reissue.
An old classic.
But like,
it,
it's required reading for an informed citizen of the 21st century.
It's not optional.
You need to know this material.
You're not,
you're not,
you don't understand your position in society as an individual or a citizen
without knowing this material.
So it's like not knowing about what happened in Nazi Germany.
It's not acceptable to not know.
So read the book.
Thanks for coming,
George.
Really good to see you again man.
Absolutely.
Yeah,
you bet.
I appreciate it.
And with that Jordan Peterson has departed the recording studio.
And if you noticed that Echo Charles was not present during the recording with
Jordan Peterson,
but through the miracle of technology and recording echo has now joined us for
the support portion of this podcast.
So good evening echo.
Good evening.
All right.
So,
uh,
if people listen to this podcast,
which we appreciate and you want to support this podcast and support yourself,
there are ways to do that.
Echo can fill you in.
Sure.
So first way is when you're doing jujitsu cause we're all doing Jujitsu.
Yes,
it might sound a little bit repetitive,
but to me when you do this,
you're going to be doing it every single day,
every single week at least.
Even if you're doing the two times a week,
three to get it.
Either way,
you're gonna need a g and a rash guard.
So there is no question which kind of Geeky you get.
You get an origin gay,
straight up made in America.
I watched one of their videos yesterday and it's kind of an older one too,
but it made me like love origin even more because it's like you'll see,
you know the people that make 'em and all the ladies there and then Pete like he
has like longer hair and stuff like that.
It's like,
Oh man,
this is kind of more the beginnings of origin,
you know.
Anyway,
I thought it was good unless again made in America quality stuff for Jujitsu.
It's not like a blank geeky they get from over wherever some other place and
then slap an embroidered patch on it.
And I say that no,
this has made four digit two in America made in America from where where we
grow.
The material is grown in America,
woven in America,
woven in Maine.
As a matter of fact costume woven by origin.
We,
we,
we've it up there and make the best geese in the world.
Also got some other stuff for,
you know,
you got t shirts,
you can get sweatshirts and also coming in 2019 jeans,
denim origin denim.
I just call them jeans though.
Yeah,
yeah,
I dig it.
That starts to like,
I dunno,
move towards a fashion thing.
What if you see Denim Denim?
Well,
I feel,
yeah,
I didn't feel that material.
Yeah,
I feel like it's like origin denim,
they make it,
you know?
Yeah.
And then,
yeah,
they make origin jeans for sure.
But what if they make like a Jean Jacket?
Like a denim jacket?
No,
that'd be true.
But it's still be a Jean Jacket.
That's true.
Uh,
dig it.
Cool.
Either way.
Yeah,
that's,
and I don't get excited for jeans in general in life.
Oh yeah.
Like you know,
you see it on TV.
I don't know.
JC Penny has a sale,
you know,
black Friday or whatever and you know,
some jeans I don't get excited.
Do you pride,
I'm assuming you don't need there.
Maybe do,
I dunno,
but when Pete posts little like videos of the close,
you know,
close up of the buttons,
the jeans come on Brown.
That's it.
That's kind of exciting.
I'm just saying either way.
Yeah.
Either way.
The also we have supplements to affirmative forigin labs,
which is expanding.
Yes.
Yeah.
We bought another building up there,
but yeah,
so they're making,
we are making supplements,
joint warfare,
Krill oil supercrew oil,
by the way.
Discipline that Tri Fecta.
Yeah.
The My,
my wife went on a trip,
didn't take joint warfare with her.
Yeah.
She's there for three,
four days.
Her knee starts bothering her.
It bothers her the rest of the trip.
She comes home,
she goes back on joint warfare for three or four days.
Nice,
fine.
Again,
same.
Same.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
That's just a reality of it.
So join warfare,
good for your joints.
Krill oil also good for your joints and good for your,
if for your whole life system.
Is that a thing?
Life system life says yes.
Okay,
well that's good for that to discipline when you need that focus and also
discipline go.
Yeah.
Which is my pre cognitive enhancement tool.
Go to go to check.
Yeah.
It's funny,
the Krill,
I had the same situation too,
by the way.
Krill oil and join Waterford didn't bring it by the way,
in Hawaii,
which is the reason why it didn't appear on this episode of the podcast.
You know,
I saw my father in law came,
I told them the story about how he'd always talk about Krill oil and he's just
sort of looking at me like whatever.
And um,
you know,
he used to tell me,
Oh yeah,
Krill oil is good,
good for you,
all this stuff.
And he said,
not listen because you know,
he's more of like a health dude.
He's nine.
And then when you started talking about it,
like literally the day you start talking,
right,
start taking it.
And he was like,
he didn't care.
It kind of went right over his head and he was like,
oh,
so did you feel the difference?
You know,
like that's what he was concerned about.
What do you mean care respect?
Also on top of that,
he's got bulk,
which is,
which is milk basically.
That's what it is.
It's uh,
it has protein in it.
You mix it with milk.
I got her back.
I had to make that statement.
If you mix it with,
well,
you can mix it with almond milk.
You can mix it with coconut milk.
You can mix it with regular cow milk.
If you mix it with water,
it's not,
I'm not jumping up and down about it and telling you it's the most delicious
thing in the world.
If you mix it with milk,
whole milk especially,
I will tell you it's,
it's a,
it's a dessert straight up.
It's a dessert that you will make you stronger if so,
you know,
like hot cocoa.
You ever make hot?
Oh yeah.
Okay.
So I'm a fan that you can put in water,
right?
What do you put it in?
Water and milk.
That is not hot cocoa to me.
Okay.
I know what you're talking about.
You get the little,
the little packet that you're supposed to mix with water,
it's got the little crappy marshmallows in it.
Yeah.
That's not,
that's a nonstarter for me.
Yeah.
So that's kind of the point there.
It's sort of the,
you know,
along the same lines where it's like,
cool,
do it.
It's okay.
You can do it.
Yup.
And there's probably many,
many,
many people who do that and I'm not mad at them,
but you put the milk,
that stuff and you know,
that's the good one.
That's my opinion.
And by the way,
you can't have,
you can't have hot chocolate milk.
It's good.
It's right up there.
She don't worry kid one.
Yeah,
the surrogate mint chocolate peanut butter,
chocolate,
vanilla gorilla and the darkness.
And then there's the warrior kid mark,
which has a little bit less protein in it unless you double up on your scoops
like I do for the strawberry,
cause it's a strawberry is ridiculously good.
So give that a shot.
And by the way,
all these things are available@originmain.com and that's,
that's the state of Maine.
Yeah.
Not just main,
like the main spot.
Even though it is a main spot check.
Cool.
Awesome.
Yeah.
Also if you want to represent,
you know,
get a discipline equals freedom shirt or a rash,
get after it.
You know,
you want to represent the path,
go to Jocko,
store.com.
That's where you can get all this stuff.
Uh,
hoodies,
you know,
hey,
Christmas is coming up.
Let's face it.
There's no avoiding it.
It's coming up,
you know,
so you want to grab something that's a good place to grab something.
Some new stuff on there too.
But yeah,
if you want to represent while on the path,
Jocko,
store.com good spot.
Also Jocko white tea.
So these claims of dead lifting,
8,000 pounds I haven't did lifted in awhile.
So it was like,
you know what I'm going to do?
I'm going to test it.
The cans,
right tea,
drink it straight up,
dead lifts,
dead lifts at 8,000 pounds.
Just like that.
No warm up even know you don't need it.
It's real.
Or The warmup is drinking some Jocko white tea.
That is the one you're warmed up and you're good.
He thousand pound deadlifts or yeah,
that's the old,
this is the only product in the world in any capacity that guarantees 100% 8,000
pound deadlift.
Minimum.
100% but yeah.
So yeah,
you get them wet and the dry tea bags,
if that's your thing.
When you see Paul,
that's the word,
right?
Steep,
steep,
boom.
If you like that Gig,
hot,
cold,
whatever.
And then the cans,
which I recommend I recommend they can actually,
I don't know if I'd recommend it,
but I prefer that I like them both.
Yeah.
Depending on the scenario of her boom,
there you go.
Also subscribe to the podcast on iTunes and stitcher and Google play.
Wherever you listen to podcasts is a lot of new ones out there.
There's little apps and there's a lot of podcasts out there and listen to a
bunch of them and one of them that you can also listen to in addition to this
one,
if you want,
you can turn up the warrior kid podcast that's basically directed at kids.
But um,
I'll tell you that uncle Jake has lessons for everyone in every podcast.
And also we got the youtube channel,
the youtube channel where you can watch this podcast in its full length and you
can see what people look like.
If you don't know what Jordan B.
Peterson looks like,
if you don't know what Echo Charles look like or if you don't know what I look
like,
you can watch the,
the youtube channel and you can see all of us.
If you never heard,
if you've never seen echo before,
but you've only heard him,
he probably doesn't look like what you'd think he looks like.
Yeah,
allegedly.
And I don't know if that's good or bad enough.
That's a backhanded compliment or a backhanded like derogatory statement about
you,
about your voice?
Probably both.
Yeah,
a little bit of both but,
but we'll,
we'll uh,
suffice it to say that he's not what you expect when you see him in reality.
And he also makes videos that are enhanced by imagery and music.
Exactly.
And those are on there too,
so you can check those out.
You can subscribe to the Youtube Channel.
Also,
we got the psychological warfare album and that has tracks on it of,
well there are of me telling you pragmatically why you should or should not do
something like skip a workout.
You should not skip a workout.
Eat donuts.
You should not eat donuts.
So just some little things like that.
You can check that out.
Psychological Warfare Echo claims that it has 100% effectiveness.
Yeah,
it does.
100% should you go to the gym?
Yes.
You should.
And if you listen to the track,
you will go to the gym.
It's 100% effective.
And actually,
I mean a lot of claims being made about effectiveness on this scenario,
right?
Hey,
it's,
it's real.
It's real.
You know,
there's no double blind placebo tested it.
Well,
you know,
single blind maybe.
Okay.
Do you know what that means?
But that's not official and it is official when,
okay.
I,
and I kind of,
I tried to psychologically analyze psychological warfare.
Like why does it work every single time?
And here's part of it.
Even you,
you know how like when you get hypnotized,
I'm not saying you should have,
I should have asked.
I should have asked Jordan this question.
Yes.
And he did agree with this,
I think.
I think,
well maybe next let's,
here it goes bro.
Theory.
So you know,
like I'm being hypnotized.
For example,
you,
I've never been hypnotized.
Yeah,
me neither.
So well,
but then again,
it's real and something happens to.
So have you ever said volunteer?
Did he admit okay,
me neither.
Same thing.
So hypnotism,
from what I understand is you have to like be,
what do you call like successful,
open to it.
Open to it.
Yeah.
So if you're a suggestible person that's like you have a certain kind of mind.
And then on top of that,
even more consciously,
you have to volunteer to be hypnotized.
A Guy,
I mean,
I'm sure there's methods that you can sort of hypnotize someone without them
knowing it or something.
But usually,
I shouldn't even say I'm sure,
but,
oh yeah,
that's right.
It,
you can hit them dead zone and they are not.
Nonetheless,
usually the hypnotic sequence goes from,
hey,
you volunteer like conscious of,
yeah,
sure,
I'll be hypnotizing you sit there and your troop count to 10 and you're closing
your eyes and breathing anyway.
So you consciously volunteer to be hypnotized.
So you're open to being hypnotized and then blah,
blah,
blah.
So psychologic warfare is like,
hey,
you recognize,
okay,
I have this weakness.
I'm about to skip this workout right now.
You're basically saying,
hey,
I need help.
I need,
you know,
I need a little spa volunteering for help volunteering yet it's not like I'm
like sitting in my room.
It's not completely against your will.
Exactly right.
You're not just busting in the door,
you know insane.
Hey,
don't skip the workout.
Meanwhile in your mind,
you already committed to keeping,
the way it's different is you're like,
you're not committed to skipping the workout.
You just like are running the risk of skipping the work.
You know that weakness just creeps in and you're like,
hey,
I see you weakness you're creeping in right now.
I'm going to get,
I'm basically,
I'm going to tell Jocko that you're in here and he's going to,
you know,
make you leave and you played that track or whatever.
You have it on your phone,
right?
You had,
you have all your playlist on your phone anyway.
You just play the psychological warfare one and boom,
you won't skip to work out.
See what I'm saying?
Cause you don't want to skip the workout.
No one wants to skip the work on.
No one's thinking tomorrow.
I cannot wait to skip this workout.
And that is not like that,
you know,
so it's,
you come in and you just give that little nudge.
That's why it works so good.
It's true.
It's absolutely true.
I like it.
The less psychological warfare,
it's very effective.
Hundred percent.
Also while you're working out and if you're bored with your squats bench,
get some kettlebells from on it,
in my opinion on it.com/jocko good stuff on their jump rope,
battle ropes,
kettlebells clubs may be careful of the clubs.
Costco,
I was watching a video of a guy doing this club routine.
I was like,
Dang it,
eat.
It took a lot of coordination.
Like I'm looking at it and he had like the 40 I think like a big one.
Yeah.
I can't even imagine trying to do anything coordinated with the 40 yes,
because I only have the 20 yeah and yeah,
and they come off real a lot more heavy than they look like when you grab them.
I mean,
at the end of the day,
if it's 20 pounds,
20 pounds,
no,
there's no getting past that physically,
but when you pick it up,
it's like,
you know when you pick up your friend or your kid freaking and they weighed 70
pounds,
it's like I pick up 70 pounds with one hand.
It's no problem when it's a dumbbell should pick up your kid when they're 70
pieces of one hand can do it.
It's hard.
Unless that's how these clubs are.
Anyway,
so watch out for those.
go to [inaudible] dot com slash jock we can get some really cool stuff on there.
Really cool.
Awesome.
Hey,
we got some books as well.
First off,
Mike and the dragons.
I know Jordan and I talked to about it a little bit today and it was actually
sold out for a little bit.
It is now back in stock and have many,
many,
many thousands and thousands of copies that are inbound that are being printed.
So if you want Mickey in the dragons,
go to Amazon and order it.
There's a little video on there if you want to know what it's about that echo,
but together and it's a,
it's,
it's a solid video from what I understand,
the kids like to watch the video.
Oh,
you get like,
it's like a little mini show.
It's super fast.
It's two minutes.
And even even my kids,
so we're on,
I watched the video
send it to me.
I watched it like 14 times because there's a lot of elements in it.
There's a lot of things going on.
Yeah.
To my Saad,
it's like a micro cartoon Kinda.
No,
it's like a micro movie.
Yeah.
Like,
well it's a cartoon because there's illustrations.
Illustrations.
Yeah.
But yeah,
it's fun.
We put it on the TV when I was in Hawaii,
you know,
you have smart TV and there you can put youtube on there.
I put on the TV and my kids are all jumping up and down,
like in the is if I have is,
you know,
it's two minutes long.
So,
no,
I,
you know,
uh,
Jordan and I were talking about it
and you know,
obviously it's about facing your dragons and there's obviously a metaphor there
and it's a real true pragmatic,
simple to understand lessons of how to stand up and confront the world and
confront your fears that little kids will clearly and easily understand and
it'll leave an impact on anybody that reads it.
So Mike,
in the dragons that you can get that book on top of that,
if you've got kids,
you can also get them to the way of the warrior kid,
which is another book about a young kid who's going through the problems that
normal kids have.
And luckily his uncle Jake,
who was a seal in the seal teams,
it shows up for the summer and helps them overcome those problems.
And then that series carries on and another book called Mark's mission.
You can pick those two books up and give them to whatever kids you those,
those books.
When you read those books,
you'll wish you had that book when you were a kid.
I know.
I absolutely wish I had that book when I was a kid and I wish I had that book
when my kids were kids.
Yeah,
because it teaches them what it is they need to know.
Period.
That's it.
Uh,
the discipline equals freedom field manual.
That book,
that's how you,
that's how you is.
It's just a field manual of how to be on the path of discipline.
That's what it is.
Look at the path of discipline is not easy and there's no field manual for it.
Oh wait,
there is now there didn't used to be there.
Didn't used to be.
Look,
I know discipline will help me.
How do I get disciplined?
Where does discipline come from this?
None of that information was assembled anywhere.
I made a field manual for it.
It's called the discipline equals freedom field manual.
It's not,
it's not like any other book you've ever seen or read,
period.
It's not,
but it's very popular.
It's great if you want it.
This is another thing.
Chris,
did you say Christmas is coming and this is a Christmas scenario,
right?
This is a Christmas scenario.
Give this book to somebody that needs help or needs to stay on the path or get
on the path.
This book will be extremely beneficial to them or people that are on the path
getting after it.
This will keep them there.
So that's the field manual.
If you want the audio version of that,
it is not an audible,
it's on iTunes and Amazon music and Google play as an MP3.
Also,
the first book I wrote with my brother Leif Babin,
it's called extreme ownership.
That is a book taking the leadership lessons that we learned on the battlefield
and translating them to your business and to your life.
And then the followup to that book is the dichotomy of leadership,
which takes those lessons that we learned in combat and goes granular in
teaching you how to balance the various dichotomies that you experience as a
leader.
So both and all those books are available on Amazon and wherever else you might
do buy books.
Also,
we've got echelon front,
which is,
uh,
my leadership consultancy.
We solve problems through leadership.
That's what we do.
And we work with companies all over the country and internationally.
If you want us to come and align the leadership at your company for victory,
then go to echelon front.com the we are do we have a leadership conference
called the muster and we've done six monsters.
We are doing three and 2019 we're doing one in Chicago in the spring.
We're doing one in Denver in the fall and we're doing Sydney,
Australia in December.
So if you want to come to one of those events,
all the events that we've done have sold out all of them.
These are all absolutely going to salt sell out.
So if you want to come,
go to extreme ownership.com and register and as quick as you can.
And then lastly we have f Overwatch.
We are connecting special operations veterans and Combat Aviation veterans that
are looking for work that are proven leaders that are experienced leaders and
we're connecting them with companies out there in the civilian sector that need
leaders.
So if you want to come at that from either side,
whether you're a vet or whether you're a company,
go to e f overwatch.com to get in the game and if you have any more questions
for us or answers for us,
we are available on the interwebs,
on Twitter and on Instagram and on the fee ease.
The bookie echo was adequate.
Charles and I am at jockowillink and I started out this podcast today pretty
heavy,
pretty rough and I think it's important to remember something that I always
refer back to and that is that evil does exist in the world.
It's out there.
And with that I'd like to thank all the military personnel throughout the globe
that stand up to evil in the world and thanks to police and law enforcement and
firefighters and paramedics and EMT,
ies and correctional officers and border patrol and all the first responders
that stand up and face evil here at home and to everyone else out there,
if things are tough and I know they get tough,
life is hard.
Okay?
But there's still reason to be thankful.
Be Thankful you're not in the gulag.
Be Thankful that you're not being tortured.
Be Thankful that you have food to eat.
Be thankful you have a bed to sleep on,
and then do your best to watch out for those little seeds of evil that are
planted around you.
Yeah.
Implanted in you
and keep those seeds of evil in check by going out into the world and doing
good.
Okay.
And until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.